determina el perímetro del siguiente
paralelogramo ok en un paralelogramo los
lados opuestos son paralelos este de
aquí es paralelo a este de acá este de
acá que voy a pintar en naranja es
paralelo a este de acá y además los
lados opuestos deben de medir lo mismo
así que esto pues si tiene chance de ser
un paralelogramo bueno para obtener el
perímetro lo que queremos es el
perímetro
tenemos que pensar esto como si fueran
osea digamos un campo y que este campo
lo queremos cercar entonces si tenemos
un campo con la forma de este
paralelogramo cuantas cerca necesitamos
para rodearlo y bueno eso claramente se
obtiene sumando las longitudes de todos
los lados 12 8 + 12 8 este 6.5 que nos
dan no lo vamos a utilizar al parecer en
este problema es información demás bueno
entonces el perímetro nos quedaría igual
a 12 más 8 más 12 más 8 12 8 es 2012
2020 + 20 es igual a 40 y con eso
terminamos el perímetro es 40 pulgadas
pulgadas y chin creo que esto es algo
muy pequeño para que sea realmente un
campo hay algunas televisiones que
tienen más de 40 pulgadas tan solo en la
diagonal pero bueno entonces puede ser
una pequeña parcela de tierra con forma
de paralelogramo y con perímetro 40
pulgadas